[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels heute gebe es ein ganz einfaches
rezept was ihr euch schon lange
gewünscht habt ich mache nämlich
franzbrötchen und zwar kennt man diese
spezialität in hamburg das ist eine art
plunder teig wird aber auch aus hefeteig
gemacht ich mache jetzt heute mit
plunder teig und plunder teig ist im
prinzip ein hefeteig mit butter das wird
geschichtet und deswegen entstehen dann
im backofen beim backen diese einzelnen
schichten klar ist da viel butter zu
reden und viel zucker aber die französin
echt lecker wir haben dem murat mal
probiert nämlich nur moralisch peter
ihres in hamburg weil man mir damals
genau
und da habe ich die im hotel gegessen
und die sind echt super lecker ich
dachte eigentlich immer warum fragen
denn immer alle danach aber
franzbrötchen solltet ihr wirklich mal
ausprobiert haben
ich zeige euch jetzt mal den hefeteig
und daraus entsteht dann später beck
plunder teig für den hefeteig nämlich
einem würfel hefe 30 gramm lauwarmes
wasser 80 gramm zucker 220 gramm warme
milch einen teelöffel salz 500 gramm
mehl dann nehme ich jetzt ein dinkelmehl
etwas zitrone abrieb oder zitronen
passte und 80 gramm weicher butter
zuerst verrührt jetzt wie immer die hefe
mit dem wasser und zucker
da wird ein vorteig er hergestellt
hergestellt hergestellt da wird ein
vortrag hergestellt naja jetzt und den
könnt ihr jetzt gerne entweder kurz
abdecken und bei raumtemperatur so 15
minuten stehen lassen oder einfach im
dampf backofen bei der stufe da dauert
etwa nur 67 minuten oder auch direkt in
der küchenmaschine steht auch nicht so
funktion die hefe es gut aufgegangen und
jetzt könnt ihr im prinzip einfach alle
zutaten miteinander verkneten
ich achte immer darauf dass ich fett und
salz ganz zum schluss zum teig gebe hier
direkt das mülheim und wie gesagt habe
ich jetzt hier ein dinkelmehl ihr könnt
aber auch in weizen mail benutzen
die milch ist jetzt auch schon lauwarm
der restliche zucker rheins als niemals
vergessen beim hefeteig
das alles ist echt mega wichtig entweder
ein bisschen zitronen abrieb von einer
bio zitrone oder einer unbehandelten
zitrone oder etwas passte
[Musik]
und jetzt macht die weiche butter dazu
und dann in etwa fünf bis sieben minuten
einen geschmeidigen hefeteig nähten geht
natürlich auch mit der hand mit der
maschine habe ich einfach beide hände
frei und kann so lange aufräumen
[Musik]
so sieht der hefeteig jetzt aus richtig
schön
ich freue mich jetzt zu einer kugel und
dann kommt da ihm die schlüssel zurück
ich hätte die vorher mit etwas back
james craig und da kommt auch etwas
marktrend spray obendrauf trocknet er
nicht aus und jetzt lasse ich ihn
abgedeckt für eine stunde auf gehen oder
mit wärme für etwa eine halbe stunde
[Musik]
der teig ist jetzt gut aufgegangen dann
stelle ich kurz zur seite
hier habe ich 200 gramm ganz kalte
butter ich hatte die sogar
gefrierschrank denn jetzt schneide ich
sie in vier scheiben
[Musik]
und da kann ich jetzt schon mal den
hefeteig ausrollen
ihr könnt das rezept übrigens auch ganz
einfach vegan machen indem ihr einfach
pflanzen mensch nimmt und veganer butter
ich habe jetzt auch keine im teig
also gehen auch megane franzbrötchen es
hatte ja auch mal ein veganes hefegebäck
auf dem blog oder in meinen videos das
war auch echt mega das waren so
schokoladentörtchen jetzt ein rechteck
ausrollen portabler kein lege ich jetzt
hier rein
jetzt kommt die andere hälfte darüber
und die ränder werden jetzt schön
zugedrückt
das mag ich jetzt hier noch drüber und
hier und jetzt der länge nach auf rollen
als auseinander rolle ausrollen
das war das wort was fehlte jetzt
verteilt sich die butter hier schön drin
und gleichmäßig jetzt habe ich eine
platte die etwa 30 x 45 cm groß die
drittel ich jetzt und dann liegen diese
butter schichten in drei schichten
übereinander
und jetzt halbwegs hier nochmal und habe
einen schönen hefeteig block und so kühl
ich den teig jetzt erst mal aber mehr
wird jetzt hier auch nicht gefaltet das
ist ja kein klassisches plundergebäck
sondern soll wirklich nur ein paar
schichten haben den denke ich jetzt noch
ab da kommt er in den kühlschrank für
etwa 15 minuten und dann wird gleich
weitergemacht
guckt mal datei geht sogar im
kühlschrank wunderbar auf und jetzt
rolle ich ihn aus zu einer großen platte
man sieht auch richtig schön die butter
dazwischen
[Musik]
und jetzt bestreitet diese platte mit
wasser ich habe jetzt fast quadratisch
ausgerollt 50 50 und das wasser bewegt
jetzt dass der zucker dran haftet und
dieser zucker der wird dann im ofen
gleich karamellisieren und dadurch kommt
eben dieser schöne geschmack zustande
ich habe ich jetzt 200 gramm zucker und
einen esslöffel zimt das möchte ich
jetzt so miteinander dass wir jetzt hier
direkt drauf gestreut
die rolle die ich jetzt ein bisschen
länger damit sie vom durchmesser her
einfach dünner wird und jetzt schneide
ich das immer im zickzack also einmal so
rum das messer halten einmal andersrum
halten und schneidet hier kleine stücke
ab das sieht man richtig schön schon die
füllung
die kommen jetzt aufs blech mit schönen
abstand auflegen
denn die gehen gleich noch auf
[Musik]
ich habe nochmal leicht mit mehl
bestreuen
um sie dann einzudrücken entweder nimmt
er jetzt ein kochlöffel stil oder zum
beispiel den pinsel und die zehen damit
schönen eindrücken und die seiten die
kommen dann gleich durchs becken so ein
bisschen raus bevor ich sie jetzt packe
lasse ich sie noch mal raufgehen dafür
stelle ich sie aber in den kühlschrank
damit die butter noch mal schön fest
werden kann und wirklich dann beim
backen diese einzelnen schichten
entstehen
und dann kommen sie nacheinander in den
backofen die franzbrötchen die ware
jetzt im kühlschrank ich hatte sie sogar
länger drin das heißt wenn es hier
vorbereiten wollte könnte jetzt gut
vorbereiten in den kühlschrank stellen
und dann kurz vor dem verzehr backen wie
so heißen die eigentlich franzbrötchen
ich nenne sie jetzt franz und franziska
brötchen ich finde alle
gleichberechtigung oder j franz und
franziska und dann kann man sich
aussuchen wer franz und franziska von
franziska wandernetz in den backofen bei
200 grad ober unterhitze und da
karamellisieren sie ist auch richtig
schön und dann probieren wir sie noch
ganz warm
[Musik]
meine franz und franziska brötchen sind
gebacken und am besten schmecken sie
wirklich lauwarm
so sehen sie aus meinte sind etwas
hübscher nicht ganz so hübsch aber das
macht nichts
und hier seht ihr schon richtig gut wie
der zucker an der oberfläche
karamellisiert ist und ich glaube ich
hoffe jetzt einfach niemanden dazu dass
wir 2 wir probieren die kante hat danach
die kamera nicht mehr bedienen weil
zucker und fett
man hört auch so ein bisschen der zucker
der knuspert so
lecker lecker aus wirklich also die
praktisch auf jeden fall wieder und ihr
könnt wie gesagt auch gleich die
doppelte menge machen
ich habe jetzt daraus knapp 15 stück
glaub ich bekomme ich schreibe es auf
jeden fall auf den block probiert das
rezept gerne mal aus postet eure fotos
und genauen eure nachgemachten werke
unter dem hashtag sallys welt um
franzbrötchen oder franz und franziska
ich weiß nicht genau ich schreibe hier
unten was rein dann wirst du auf jeden
fall bescheid ich freue mich auf eure
fotos denn dieses rezept wurde wirklich
oft angefragt also viel spaß und nach
backen und bis zum nächsten mal
ich mache
[Musik]